Patrick mahomes what's up my Holmes
Chiefs quarterback I got the Broncos
coming up play T Texas Tech started at
Texas A&M his dad was a really good
quarterback as well he's dead you know
played some baseball as well so
interesting interesting pedigree there I
had the win over the Bengals and he
threw for four touchdowns and just one
interceptions on the season he's got 22
touchdowns and five interceptions the
Chiefs quarterback Patrick mahomes
joining us good morning Patrick if if
you could pick out one highlight that
would sum up your season so far what's
the highlight that you would want us to
see
I mean selfishly I would say the
scramble around I threw the touchdown
the Chris Conley in the back of the
endzone against the 49ers but I think
one of the fair plays was the touched on
the Tyreke against the Patriots just in
that situation and being able to step up
in the pocket and make that throw and
then him make that play was pretty sweet
do you have doubts going into games no
not at all I mean especially with this
team and with this this wet repertoire I
have of weapons around me I know that I
don't have to try to do too much and I
feel like that's the biggest thing
that's gotten me to this point this
season is I'm not trying to do too much
I'm just trying to be myself and run
this offense how it's supposed to be ran
and let the big plays come Aaron Rodgers
said there are times he goes to the line
of scrimmage he'll just look at coverage
and he knows it's going to be a
touchdown have you had one of those
moments or a couple of those moments
this year I mean definitely know there's
gonna be a big play I mean you could go
up there sometimes and you know that
you've kind of scripted scripted those
plays just for this coverage and you
know that their defense does it this way
and so there are certain plays
especially when you have a guy like
Tyreke and you can see that they're not
deep enough to guard him running down
the field that I know there's a good
chance is gonna be a big play can Tyreke
he'll outrun your arm yeah I mean I
haven't overthrown him yet he's someone
that can roll then I mean he's the
fastest person I've ever seen
I believe if he was a if he was on the
track
on track he's been in the Olympics and
he'd have been on that 100 meter dash so
I mean it's coming that I got a I got a
little early if I went over to them okay
what's it like in the huddle when
everybody comes back all these star
players and everybody says they're open
and they want the football how do you
keep everybody in the huddle happy
everybody
I mean honestly no one's calling
football no one's trying to get the ball
every single time everybody knows what
the plays the coach recalls that
everybody's get a chance to make a play
and so for me it makes it really easy on
me I can just go through my read and and
everybody's gonna kind of get theirs and
score touchdowns what was it like you're
playing you know I can't help but
imagine you going back you know when
you're in college and you're watching
football on Sunday and all of a sudden
you know there's Tom Brady playing and
then a couple of years later you're
right there going toe to toe with him
and what's the experience like yeah you
don't really realize it I mean you're
just going out there and trying to
compete but I mean you look back on it I
mean it is pretty clear it is really
cool to think about to get to play
against someone and that's that team and
of that caliber that you I mean kind of
watch the balls come up to see him
playing and so for me this year better
play against a lot of great quarterbacks
that have seemed good for a long time
and I'm glad I have my teammates and we
can go out there and compete against
them how often you miss baseball I
really don't miss it that much I mean
the only times I ever really miss it or
I mean like he wants for a World Series
or something like that
some of the big games I mean I think if
I was like dang I could be playing
baseball or if I once I headed over to
the Royals game yet still out the first
pitch this offseason and just kind of
got in the cage in took a couple swings
I was like dang miss a little bit at the
same time I'd enjoy football so much and
I'm still learning and still I get to
really just enjoy the benefits of that
what's tougher playing quarterback or
trying to hit a baseball I think I mean
both of them are very tough things I
think playing quarterback personally
just because there's so many decisions
you have to make a split amount of time
but I know
I know from experience I mean hitting
the baseball especially at that level is
there's no easy thing
he's Patrick my homes Chiefs quarterback
and got the Broncos coming up next game
how's the home life you cooking what's
what's going on I'm definitely not
cooking that's like one of the things
I'm not good at but uh I'm uh I'm really
much just chilling and I just studied up
on football I mean I really just I go
home i watch football on TV or I'm
looking at my place look at film and
then my girlfriend cooks for me or we
some of our like pre-made bills that we
get from this place called fist on food
and this kind of still at the house she
may change you at all I mean really look
at looked into hazing me or anything
like that but we definitely talk back to
the locker room around each other and
leave a lot of young guys and everybody
gets along and that's what makes our
team I think truly special
yeah kelsey said that he makes fun of
you he said he made fun of your voice in
the huddle a little bit there they rough
you up a little bit with that yeah
became really popular I've heard the
joke since I was in like seventh grade
so I've gotten used to it and I mean
they know I thought it starts back at
them wait where did the voice come from
I'm always added I mean I've always had
kind of the the hoarse voice I mean I
guess you'd say I mean it but I mean I
was something that came part of me and I
like to own it and I mean like I say
that I got like a second career is like
a clutch music artists or stuff myself
can you sing okay I was looking really
seeing snow on half that like that real
southern voice with the country twang to
it and I think people were like I like
that but in Kansas City they're gonna
buy anything that you're selling so I
couldn't maybe after and here the take
that route with uh you were your dad's
Mets Jersey before Sunday night's game
with the Bengals how come yeah I mean
just kind of I knew that I wanted to
show off a lot of things that he had
done and I know the Mets were kind of
when I first started remembering
playing baseball and it was one of my
favorite times in my life and so I
wanted to kind of just get the show up
that stuff him and all the success he
had and I'm he loved it and then I got
to kind of just do something for him who
have you heard from that might surprises
this year I mean good amount of people I
think one that was I mean hey Ron I
talked to him a couple of years and so
for him he reached back out to me and
messaged me on Instagram and this ho
told me Congrats on all this he said
stop I'm having and that he was proud of
this Washington play and stuff like that
so I mean I thought that was cool and
then other than that I've just been
family friends and and people that I've
met throughout my life yeah but didn't a
rod tell you there's no future in
football for you yeah I mean it was I
was young everybody thought I was gonna
be a baseball player and I mean that's
that still today I mean people thought I
was a baseball player in my high school
or if I was wondering why I went to
college to play football when I got
drafted in baseball and I mean that
that's just how I was my hometown but I
chose the right route it's worked out so
far you know it's been fun watching but
it feels like you know they wait for uh
you know that not rookie wall since
you're not a rookie but you know defense
is trying to figure you out so how much
does Andy Reed help prepare you for that
considering you know he's pretty much
seen all of it yeah I think this whole
last year that I had until now I mean
just preparing for every single defense
that you can see preparing for
everything that devious can throw at you
and then being able to experience that
this year I know we've really seen a ton
of different different defenses and
coverages and blitzes this year already
and having every time every one of those
the learning experience for me and I
know people think I'm we're gonna hit
the wall but the same time I mean when
you have the weapons that I have I mean
it's hard for defenses to do too much
does they have to account for everybody
on the field and I mean the thing is we
have run the ball so well we can pass
the ball we can do we can do pretty much
everything and the defense is playing
better and better every week and I'm
excited for just the future head I don't
know if Andy Reid saw when you were on
our
show in the New York studio and you
through the ball and you hit that big
large head of mine you put a dent in it
in the nose but that to me is what told
me you could play in the NFL none of
this other stuff hey congrats so far
Patrick please say your hello to your
parents for me and thanks for joining us
yeah thanks for having hit four more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]